welcome to this video playing rook with
black Grandmaster actor Stein I recently
want a very nice game against him and
when when we played he also was down on
the clock at the because he didn't how
is he doing this on purpose I mean back
then I gave him the minute back okay so
let's let's see maybe try the NIMS Irwin
is on track playing 93 yeah let's go
with D 6 keep it keep it simple approach
okay yeah this is a very solid position
for black having a good good control
over the the light square Bishop do very
often come to a for ya another idea that
black frequently places the move b5 and
she didn't play a for surprised me so
I'm going to going to go with this
should be for now yeah black is glad to
get this this pawns on dark square so
that he might initiate some play on on
the light squares Queen I can I can do
some more prep moves or strengthening
moves he might hmm he might go for
Bishop everyone moving the bishop efore
later
hmm how do i how do I get active here a
five maybe don't really see how I can
get in 85 I get the Queen over to be
seven or something hmm we don't be sad I
not shows sometimes c6 coming I don't
see it at the moment though yeah that
that was clear clearly has attention hmm
i have a square on c4 snide efore
leading to anything probably not yes
just playing Bishop e3 but then I can
play a fire but then f3 ok I understand
you I'm still wondering if I should go
with a five at some point
I also have this problem buffet every
year I was intending this move so that
after you for I can trade but he will
not play for it will just drop back
probably Bishop tagid no Bishop g2 I
have g5 winning the night now the night
over there hmm I I see yeah maybe still
maybe still a go for this well this I
didn't expect
g-form I'm switching back here maybe I
can get any five very complicated very
complicated strategical struggle cannot
really assess this it might be that
white is better but I still I still
don't know exactly hmm this looks weird
a bit aged five I mean my age for that
h1 looks we had to wait for wider
thought but maybe g5 is really good fam
we must play that anyway so okay what
about this my taking here will g6g six
looks very passive I rather try to play
night age 596 and get the h-bomb
yeah white is probably probably better
here it's still a very confusing
confusing position there can i go e5 how
do I get can I get as a skin in some way
quince is 795 problem
night on each form yeah this is better
for white much better for what the age
file at the end ah that was difficult
now that was a very difficult game why
instant is a difficult game but I mean
how to really hard to evaluate
interesting way to play I will have a
probably thought maybe a 5 285 to just
force open the center I h2 is hanging as
well okay I kept I don't have time to
calculate this need to need to just just
to go forward him time morning rookie 2
and h 2 is hanging I know that's a made
on g7 so ok man I can take and now take
these act as h2 hangs check
night I can't even look each one even
each one if we move the night I have
Queen f4 check
so much is this is still holding for
what
howdy overlooked something in some way
to to finish him off yeah it was bad
knowing ef5 was really bad news check
check check this is actually I like four
things I design this is this is he
better now I have a care I have have
activity but their this was a position
where I probably was outplayed around TM
it should be it should be excellent for
wider ilium it's still enormously
complicated very weird position but
white is probably better it's not clear
what this Bishop is doing and he has the
age far and this must be good for white
but very tough position ok I was trying
for Colin to play with five f4 here and
this is it from a technical point of
view somewhat risky move as it puts this
rook in that I agonal it's probably good
computer is on plus 1.8 I mean as
mentioned areas think you outplayed me
here and this is just a desperation move
of course now I went here but this is
not easy at all with with one minute on
the clock King g1
this is a move that once you see it you
pretty much quickly see that it's
probably probably just good I mean it
covers the edge to look but it's not so
easy to come up as a human because you
always had the idea to to get to get
looks over there so we don't think about
the move went here and this this should
really lose take stakes rookie to Jack
yeah this is sister check right I can
just take you to of course this Queen f4
yep I didn't see that I can take care
because chess is losing the house I
didn't seek winner form not at all ok
and here here here yet ok Luke age 1 and
this makes things okay for white again
went back and after that I'm again
better but ok but we had seconds rookie
one seems to be best here with white
having a slight advantage at least this
is the initial engine evaluation i have
two pawns yeah difficult they want to be
to track to critical about all that i
look at three wins ARMA tactics my
tactics chef Paul Shack yeah I suspected
there is something i didn't i didn't see
it with with this little time I would
just just took took the pawn there rook
a three yeah okay we shouldn't be too
critical bother we both that didn't have
didn't have much much time here funny
game okay thanks for watching